I'm so excited to be here but I have to
tell you why I'm so excited to be here
because there's a personal story I
actually have this boyfriend who's and
some of you might have friends like this
who's a little bit of a know-it-all and
we have a ongoing fight I mean this
one's big and it started a couple years
ago where he has a son-in-law and the
son-in-law is in college and the
son-in-law wants to go to Berkeley for
business school so the son-in-law we
were sitting around the table around
Thanksgiving and the son-in-law said
yeah you know I hope I get into Berkeley
for business school one day and he said
well you know if you don't get into
Berkeley for business school you could
just always go to Stanford night school
I said there is no night school at
Stanford what are you talking about he
doesn't know there is you could take
courses at night I said if you don't get
into Stanford
there's no correspondence course you
could take or any night school it does
not work this is not Community College
so he said there is night school at
Stanford this has been going on for two
years just so you know so I said listen
I know you don't know things about
colleges and universities and business
schools like this I did go to Princeton
I know there's no night school at
Princeton so you don't get a degree from
Princeton from going to night school it
doesn't work like that with world-class
universities so long story short what I
got the invitation to come here and my
friend Nancy gross reached out to me who
was at Princeton when I was there I said
of course I'm coming and on top of that
I've got to find the Dean of the
business school to write a letter on
Stanford Business School paper they just
on hand this is there is no night school
at Stanford so you can see this has
become an obsession with me a big issue
and we are actually flying out to go to
Miami later today and I said I am
bringing the note with me
so just as an FYI so that's one reason
why I'm excited to be here the other
reason I'm excited to be here is I am so
passionate about the topic that I'm
going to talk about today it's one that
I think has broad implications for all
of society I know you see Arielle Schwab
black investor survey this is not just a
black issue that I want to talk about
today I want to talk about something
that I think is a crisis that is
unfolding in real time and we're all
standing around and watching it but I
want to back up a little bit and tell
you a little bit more about our company
and me just as a way of setting up the
story that I'd like to talk about our
firm has been in business for 25 years
this year so this is a milestone year
for us 25 years in business my business
partner who started the firm turned 50 a
couple weeks ago and so it's really one
of those years where you sort of sit and
take stock of all the things that you do
it's actually one of the reasons that
we're changing our name this year we're
changing our name to Ariel Investments
because right now we have two names as a
company
Ariel capital management for our mutual
of our institutional business and Ariel
mutual funds for our mutual fund
business so on Monday
we become Ariel investments because
we're looking forward to the next 25
years of what we want our company to be
I've been at the firm has already
mentioned for 17 years this is the only
job I have ever had and Princeton says
that out of the graduating class of 1100
students I'm the only person who has had
the same work and home phone number
since I graduated from college so you
get a sense that consistency and things
like that are important to me but I've
also had the opportunity to work at a
really really amazing place do
unbelievably great work clearly having a
very strong eye towards hitting the
cover off the ball for our clients and
the people who trust their pension money
and their retirement money in their kids
college education to us but also what I
always like to say about what we're
doing at Ariel we're doing something
that is so much bigger than ah so much
bigger than even the work of investing
where we have this unique opportunity to
move the needle on something as I said
before that affects all of society now
our firm came into existence in a very
wonderful way my business partner John
Roger started our firm when he was 20
four years old he had been exposed to
the stock market in an extraordinarily
unusual way starting when he was 12
years old
instead of toys his father gave him
stocks every birthday and every
Christmas now I put the big emphasis on
instead of because he says in the
beginning it was not very fun he would
run to the tree and the only thing that
he would get was a white envelope and he
said the worst part if it wasn't bad
enough that you get the white envelope
no toys that we all know what happened
on Christmas Day and the days after
Christmas what do you do call your
friends what you get and he said his
friends would say oh I got the newest GI
Joe and another friend would say I got
monopoly and John would say oh I got IBM
shares that was his existence and he
said but the one thing that his father
did that was incredibly smart was it he
allowed him to keep the dividend checks
and he said the two things you don't get
when you're 12 years old you don't get
mail with your name on it
now think about it I remember
occasionally I'd accidentally get the
Publishers Clearing House sweepstakes
and I'd be running around the house
because I had a letter so you don't get
mail and even more so today because kids
are online right and then the second
thing you don't get you don't get checks
with your name on them so he said it
didn't matter if the checks were for 50
cents or fifty dollars he was getting
this free money in the mail and he got
very very excited about it
so he says he was a 12 year old with
cash flow if he wanted to buy a candy
bar he could but one of the things that
he realizes that if he reinvested the
dividends because his bother father was
buying these blue chip stocks for him
and just by way of just putting the
story in context John's family wasn't
wealthy his father was a Tuskegee Airmen
who went to college on the GI Bill went
to University of Chicago Law School
where he met John's mother the first
black woman to graduate from the
University of Chicago Law School I love
the story I asked John Roger who's turns
90 this year how did you end up going to
the University of Chicago Law School and
give you a sense of the practicality of
this man he said the line was shorter
so that tells you what we're dealing
with here so very very practical but he
had a hard start he was an orphan who
was a child of the depression it was
incredibly important for it to him that
John understood and respected money so
that's where this bias of giving him
stocks came from so jump ahead John's
graduating from high school he goes to
Princeton where he played basketball his
coach told him he had no future in
basketball so he decided that the only
other thing that he loved was the stock
market so he decided if you love the
stock market you become a stockbroker
he went and worked at William Blair &
Company the first black professional
ever to work at William Blair in their
history he quickly started to realize
that the the investment world was more
than just being a broker because he had
never had that perspective but the great
thing about Blair is that everything was
under one roof there so they had
corporate finance public finance asset
management mutual funds and he
discovered the whole world of investing
so at that point in financial services I
should say so at that point he realized
instead of being a broker he really
should be an money manager because he
had been developing this disciplined
patient approach to investing we've a
turtle as our logo it borrowed from
Aesop's fable of slow and steady wins
the race
so his patient approach was not one that
you were going to get quick you were
going to get rich being a stockbroker
because he had very very very few
transactions with his clients we on our
average stock at Ariel for more than
five years we've owned Clorox for my
entire 17 years that I've worked at
Ariel as an example so we're not the
firm that is moving in and out of things
we are buying and holding very much like
Warren Buffett does so at the at the end
of the day he started to realize maybe I
should be in this other aspect of the
business
so he went to the powers-that-be at
Blair and he said I'd like to work on
the asset management side and they said
hey listen kid you're 24 you have no
experience doing this you have no
clients we couldn't in good faith give
you people's pension money to manage so
John decided well if he couldn't do it
at Blair he'd go off and start his own
company so he said he's the accidental
entrepreneur because he couldn't get
hired there so he wouldn't hire it
himself now interestingly all the Blair
partners were extraordinary helpful in
the founding of Ariel in
ongoing development as a business put us
in touch with all the right people to
get the business started because there's
a lot to do when you start an investment
firm and ultimately as we like to say
things worked out so we started the firm
we were the first minority-owned money
management firm in the nation in 1983 as
hard as that is to believe because we
all hear about hedge funds venture
capital all these things going on today
9,000 mutual funds 9,000 mutual funds in
the newspaper we are the nine thousand
you 12 funds 500 of them are in the
newspaper
we're the only minority company that has
mutual funds in the newspaper every day
so when you think that there's we've
come a long way in my mind and based
upon what we see every day we still have
an extraordinarily long way to go based
upon the the the way that the industry
is shaped out and the lack of minority
participation in some aspects of the
financial services industry so he starts
the firm gets his first client first
million dollar client was municipal
employees of Chicago first client was
Howard University both are still clients
today and slowly the firm started to
build and you know the rest is history
as they say now I start off with Jon
story because Jon story is such a unique
story about being socialized to the
stock market and investing completely
different than my story so my story is
that I am the youngest in my family of
six kids and my oldest sister is 25
years older than me same mother needless
to say when I was growing up five girls
one boy my siblings made it clear that I
was not planned and they would say it
regularly you know things like your
sister is 25 and you're 30 years old and
you're five and she says things like we
were so nice to take you in when we
found you on the doorstep yeah so as I
like to tell people I'm still not quite
right but at least you understand and
have some compassion for why that might
be but when I was growing up we didn't
we had a boom and bust life that's the
best way to describe it my mom was a
single mom six kids and again I like I
can't even fathom that right six kids
she had four kids she got married when
she was 18 and had four kids when she
was 22
she won in a row for four years I mean
it's just mind-boggling but she had six
kids single mom and she was in real
estate and so we had this sort of boom
and bust sometimes we'd have money
sometimes we literally get evicted phone
disconnected all of those things no one
ever talked to me when I was growing
about growing up about the stock market
or investing and most times we were sort
of trying to make ends meet but the one
thing that I think happened to me during
that period I hated it so much I hated
that sense of insecurity and that sense
of not knowing what would happen that I
don't think it's an accident I actually
ended up in the financial services
industry and working for an investment
firm because for the same reason John's
father wanted him to understand money I
actually myself wanted to understand it
so that I could be financially secure
and I think it's part of the reason that
I am so passionate about the topic of
financial literacy and what I think is
going on in society so that was my
perspective I came to Ariel as an intern
between my sophomore and junior year
between my junior and senior year I went
and worked at tiro price for their
portfolio management team that runs
their famous New Horizons fun I was like
to tell people I got my job at t rowe
price because Ariel was the largest
shareholder of zero price and John
called them and asked them if I could
work there and the joke at T Row is that
they were training me for John which is
okay so I ended up coming back to Ariel
after I graduated from college slowly
rising up through the organization
through incredible work as you all have
done and know so well so it's nothing
that is unusual to you and ultimately in
May of 2000 became president of the firm
at an unusual situation in that when I
was very young at the firm John told me
I was going to be President and he told
me that our board said I had to be 30
which I have to be honest with you kind
of pissed me off I was not happy about
that but they felt that I needed to
mature as a person and mature as a
leader and that hard work alone which
was something I was famous for during
those years was not enough and so at 30
they lived up to their commitment and
made me president I'll never forget when
John told me we had gone to meet with
Jay sherrod and I don't know if you know
that name Jay sherrod ran a very famous
investment management firm called Miller
and
and share it that ended up being bought
by Morgan Stanley very very well-known
very famous in the investment business
and we always would go out to try to
meet with people to learn from them so
Jay had gone to Princeton he had been on
the board of Princeton when John was
there and John said we'd love to just
get some advice for you about the
business and Jay said well the only time
I could really meet with you is when I'm
on a train going from New York to
Philadelphia so we flew to New York just
to get on the train to ride to
Philadelphia with him so that we could
ask him questions along the way and I
remember we're sitting on the train and
we've prepared and you know had very
specific things we wanted to ask and
John said well you know Melody's going
to be President one day I was like 23
years old and I'm looking at him like
what are you talking about but he said
you know I want to just make sure we
start training her today for the job
that she's going to have and all that I
need her to do now I think it was
actually a very unusual and smart thing
because then I knew what I was working
towards I never had wanderlust I never
wondered about the grass being greener
on the other side of the fence
I knew my future was secure and I knew
where I was going so I ended up being
president but all along the way one of
the things we started to see is we were
going out into lots of different
communities is that there was this
disconnect in terms of audiences in
terms of just investors at Arial between
African Americans and white Americans
and we started to see more and more just
regardless of race there was a financial
literacy issue going on in this country
that actually started to come to a bull
boil and the reason it started to come
to a boil is that more and more
companies have gotten rid of the
traditional pension you have your 401k
plan you go you get your first job you
pick your investment options that have
huge implications for not only the rest
of your life in your retirement security
but also what wealth you'll pass out
your children or grandchildren so real
implications and we said we are as a
society handing the keys to people's
financial future but we have not taught
them how to drive and we searched and
realized there is a huge huge problem
going on in this country when it comes
to just knowing the basics about
investing so I decided to test the
thesis you know that I work on Good
Morning America once a week and world
news tonight as well I do all their
stories on the Stockmar
and investing so we said I'm going to
stand on the street and ask people
financial charms in downtown Chicago and
see what happens and I'm going to show
you very quick excerpt of the video to
show you what I think is at hand for
this society if you could roll the first
video please well we thought we'd put
financial contributor Mellody Hobson on
this and see what she could find out
about what we all really know she's
president of Ariel Capital Management in
Chicago she invests a lot of money for a
lot of people and she joins us now you
make the point to me which i think is
interesting that each of us thinks were
the only person who doesn't exactly know
what a bond is for instance that's right
and the amazing thing people feel so you
know I'm stupid or I'm disappointed in
myself and actually how would you know
you don't learn about investing in most
schools in America you and went to the
street to see if you could find out
exactly what people do and don't know
and what the first question you were
asking was about the S&P 500 do you know
the answer at home here's what happened
in the street
what is S&P 500 stand for
I do not know
I don't recall Stanley
Stanley Morgan & poor's I don't know 500
I assume is a volume member and you said
that you thought somebody thought it was
a car race like the Indy 500 is right
what do people think a bear market was
what is a bear market
swine the market is good I know there's
the bear and there's the other one the
lion or whatever a bear happen I think
it was one when you buy buy buy buy buy
no that's the bull market I think I
never understand those times and in fact
a bear market bad the market is going
down usually 15 percent over a six month
period the opposite is a bull market we
want to figure out why they call them
bull and bear some say bears hibernate
others say it has to do with how they
kill their prey Bulls take their horns
and pull up stock market going up bears
bear down on their prey stock market
going down good way to remember bond
just do we really know what really what
a bond is what is it bonds a bond
that I do not know I cannot give you a
Zak definition ah how do i define that a
band belongs today to the government
fund is basically a
I don't know kind of sorry so last thing
and I already did people know what I
erased stands for is what is IRA stand
for I'm not sure but I have one
investment retirement at depth all right
I know RS if I don't right okay
I know it's funny right and in the
actual show I gave all the answers but
this is the reality that society is
looking at and it's not funny when it
comes down to again picking those
retirement options and actually picking
the investments for your kids education
or whatever it might be and no one ever
having told you how it is this works and
how you do it so this is the thing that
actually makes me crazy in Chicago
public school system you can take as an
elective in a high school woodshop or
auto but you cannot take an invest in
class now this is what I find so
interesting I always like to ask a very
simple question of audiences how many
people in this room cleaned their own
carburetor because that auto class that
maybe you taught that's that's what it
maybe you took maybe you learn that um
second question how many people in this
room Whittle furniture in your spare
time right my boyfriend took woodshop he
told me he said he took metal shop as
well so just to give you a sense this is
not something that is so hard to believe
people actually I person in my firm I
they came to watch me give a speech and
he said I took electronics for three
quarters in a high school in Chicago so
again this is not something that is sort
of made up but you can't take investing
so the idea that every single day we all
turn on the television hear the radio we
get what I call the Holy Trinity the Dow
the SP and the Nasdaq and no one ever
told us what it was not to mention going
much more beyond that for the essential
things that we need to know as a society
so as a result of that I have this
mission my mission that I wake up every
single morning running is to make the
stock market the subject of dinner table
conversation in this country because I
think if we do that will actually shift
this issue around financial literacy and
ultimately have long-term financial
security as a society the reason I've
made this my mission is because I think
there's a crisis at hand and I think
we're going to look back on this period
and we are going to find that Rome was
burning and we were all standing around
holding the cans of water because to the
extent that we don't save or invest
appropriately as a society we will find
ourselves won retiring to property
potentially or being a significant
burden on society which obviously has
huge social implications so we've been
doing this work with Charles Schwab and
company right in the neighborhood here
in the Bay Area for 10 years and we've
done something that no one has ever done
before the first year we did it by
ourselves at Ariel we did a survey on
how to black people invest versus white
people is there anything telling or
intuitive there that could let us and
have a window into into what is going on
and maybe understand the problem and fix
it
we've been doing this for a very long
time as I said after the first year
Charles Schwab came to us they saw a
story that was the lead story in The New
York Times business magazine a section
on a Sunday with John and I and they
said we think you're really onto
something and we want to be the leaders
an unbiased investor education but we
think you sit from a very unique vantage
point and we want to partner with you on
this data on an ongoing basis so hints
became the Ariel Schwab black investor
survey that has really become the
defining work on what is going on with
race and society when it comes to
investing there have been a lot of
research on gender and investing never
before we did this work if there have
been any work done on race and investing
I know I called every business school
all these professors who had specific
interests we couldn't find one piece of
data on this topic until we started to
do the research now part of the reason
that we've been so felt so strongly
about this data is this cover story now
this came after we started the effort
but I don't know how many how many of
you saw this New York Times from October
2005 magazine section we regret to
inform you that you no longer have a
pension now to you all you know young
people like us we never expected to have
a pension we even worked for companies
with pension but you know it wasn't too
long ago that if you worked at General
Motors or Ford Motor Company or or
whatever yeah industrial company or even
a regular consumer products company
you'd work for the company for 30 years
retire with a gold watch and a secure
pension that's the way it worked and we
all know family members and friends who
count on their pension to sustain them
well these days it's not that way if you
work at Amazon or Microsoft or even
Charles Schwab there's no pension fund
there there's only a defined
contribution 401k plan and that 401k
plan is you in the driver's seat making
the decision about your financial future
and that means that it doesn't wreak
havoc on corporate earnings and they can
choose or not choose to make a match so
that is it should sort of completely
change the paradigm
complete and total shift in how
retirements will be funded in this
country now people always say to me you
know you're bashing 401k plans and I
want to assure you I am NOT in any way
I'm a believer in 401k plans and I like
the ownership that an individual needs
to take about their future but the one
thing I will tell you when they were
enacted 25 years ago
401k plans were not ever meant to be the
full retirement solution for an
individual it was meant to be
supplemental it has turned into the full
retirement solution on top of that 80
million working Americans in this
country have no access to any kind of
company sponsored retirement plan 401k
plan or pension fund so there are a lot
of people that are completely left out
that have to take the initiative on
their own in order to secure their
retirement by going out and saving and
investing now that isn't bad enough
people would say well we've got this
wonderful safety net in America
called social security and I like to
call social security a safety net with
holes so if you're under the age of 40
it's pretty dicey if we're ever going to
see Social Security because the system
is actually going to go bankrupt in
short order so that's one thing there'll
be more people taking out of the system
than paying into it it and we have not
quite figured out how we're going to fix
that because of the number of baby
boomers who will be relying on Social
Security but you know that in of itself
maybe that will be fixed but I always
like to put into context what Social
Security really means so I went out and
did research what is the average Social
Security check in this country today the
average Social Security check in America
today is $1,000 a month now if you know
anyone who can live on $1,000 a month
tell me who that is $1,000 a month with
no other income you are in a very very
bad situation $12,000 a year if you had
no other retirement money now just to
give you a little more color no pun
intended on this issue I asked my mother
who is turning 80 years old she would
kill me if she heard me say that how
much her Social Security check was now
you have to remember in my mother's life
I'm her retirement plan okay because she
said I sent you to Princeton you know
with loans and everything but she feels
like she got me there and that it's just
payback after that right that's how she
sees the world I don't know if you all
have mothers like that but my mother
ungraduated day told me what I owed her
so just so you know and she was not
kidding and I'm still paying so long
story short my mother I said to her how
much is your Social Security stack now
when she got past being appalled that
I'd asked her the question I said mom
you could really help my research on
this so I just need to know I want a
real person that I can talk about so my
mother's Social Security check member
she had six kids and she was an
entrepreneur which means half the time
she was not paying into any social
security system
my mother's Social Security check is
$400 a month
my mother medication is $900 a month
okay so now you get a sense of why I'm
scared to death about this issue because
I think there are a lot of people in
society where this is their faith and
that is not a fate that is acceptable to
me doing what I do every day feeling
like I have a bully pulpit to make to
affect change so I mentioned the world
is changed if you just look back to 1980
40% of corporations had a pension and a
pension is not a bad deal you work for
the company you're guaranteed eighty
percent sometimes seventy percent of
your salary until you die not a bad deal
now in 2006 only 20% of American
companies are offering pensions and I
have to tell you every day another
pension fund dies so they get cancelled
they turn into a different type of plan
so this is an ongoing issue now on top
of the fact that pensions are going away
the one thing we also know as a society
we are not saving enough so we looked at
people who are actually retired today
and we asked a specific question how
much do you have say that these are
current retirees 45% had less than
$25,000 saved when they retired that's
half of retirees less than 25% so
they're going to have that $1,000 a
month Social Security that that I'm
telling you about not to tell you I I'm
sure I'm not sure you guys get this I
think you do we get Social Security
statements now so it tells us what we
can plan for mine says that I'm going to
get $2,100 a month when I'm 65 which I
don't think is going to buy groceries
right when you add inflation and
everything else so 45% of people here
had less than $25,000 21% had between 25
and $100,000 and a third basically had
more than $100,000 saved for retirement
so this is the situation that we're
looking at now the thing about this
situation that becomes even more
challenging and something that we've
worried a lot about is this situation
changes when you looked at look at it
based upon race so if this weren't bad
enough when you look at all of society
we've been doing this research for a
decade so what is the median total
savings black versus whites a decade ago
we asked the question
african-americans on average had $30,000
safer retirement these are African
Americans and white Americans making
$50,000 in household income or more
nearly identical aged about 50 years old
nearly identical education level so
these are two people virtually the same
just different colors of their skin
black Americans had $30,000 white
Americans had 68 on average we asked the
same question last year the black number
was $48,000 a decade later the white
number was a hundred half the savings so
again the it's not even that white the
white individuals have enough money but
you cut that in half and you see that
for minorities this story gets worse
my mother always likes to say there's no
bottom to worse you know things can get
worse this is one of those examples
there's no bottom to worse things get
worse so we looked at how much are we
saving as a society a decade ago African
Americans were saving 146 dollars today
173 white Americans were saving 226 a
decade ago now 252 so we're just in
terms of the ongoing amount of money
that we're putting away we're saving a
lot less now in addition to not saving
as much as our white counterparts the
one thing that we also know from our
research we don't have the same exposure
to equities so as we all know the stock
market has outperformed all other
investments since 1926
you need stocks in your portfolio for
growth if you're sitting out the stock
market it's going to be very very hard
to grow your money and secure your
retirement so we asked a very specific
question for a decade
do you own stocks or stock mutual funds
remember almost identical scenario for
both groups of people sixteen hundred
people in this random survey in 1998
fifty-seven percent of African Americans
said that they owned stock or stock
mutual funds versus 81 percent of our
white counterparts gaping hole now this
is the thing that is so discouraging you
look at the pink chart climb by 19 by
2002 we were at 74%
a lot of us jumped in enter
net stocks bubble the stock market blew
up we completely sold out of our stocks
and white Americans just pared back and
look at how the white number is
virtually flat over those years so last
year we went back into the field and we
asked do you own stock there's document
to a Bud's a decade later and much to my
chagrin after probably thousands of
speeches I feel like Al Gore that's the
only way I feel like Al Gore after
literally I've done so many speeches on
this topic I can't count we were back at
57% so I hadn't moved the needle at all
our data hadn't moved the needle waking
up at 3:00 in the morning hadn't moved
the needle to do television nothing 57%
versus for a white counterpart 76% no we
I know there's been a tough stock market
but many of us it was our first time
being stock market investors and seeing
these kind of this kind of volatility
and when it happened we ran for the
hills though a lot of reason that I
believe we ran for the hills is because
again we have not been taught how to do
this this is our learning as you go
first place that african-americans learn
about the stock market investing is
their company 401k plan white Americans
interestingly tend to learn before they
get to their first job with some
conversation with family or friends so
it comes a little bit earlier and our
first exposure comes later and when we
are first being exposed we're making all
of these important decisions and so you
can see and I tell people all the time
this is not in any way to cast my
community in a bad light because again
there's a sense here even though you're
responsible as an individual how would
you know and when you don't know about
something and you've worked
extraordinarily hard like so many of the
minority people in this room and you're
the first person in your family actually
making a good living you don't go off
and do something willy-nilly with
something you don't know about so you
might start by putting your toe in the
water a little bit but this is not the
easiest thing to approach and it's
especially difficult when you think
about it I always like to say this to
people imagine being a bus driver or
schoolteacher in Chicago your nice
middle-class black couple
are you gonna really walk into Goldman
Sachs in the Sears Tower to talk about
investing that would be a daunting
effort now of course you Stanford
Business School that doesn't seem like a
big deal to you but you know just think
about some relatives or or people you've
known over the years of how hard it
would be even with great intentions to
tackle this and it's not like there's
I've already bladed out a lot of
diversity in the industry there was a
study a few years ago there were 90,000
stockbrokers in the United States and
600 of them were black so again it's not
like even if you wanted to you know who
to pick up and calling it's not that you
just call the black person but just
where do you start based upon the all
the social network and community that
you have right so there's some
disadvantage here I'll give you one
other point in 1994 we started
advertising every single month in Black
Enterprise magazine like Enterprise
premier black business and financial
publication we were the first mutual
fund to advertise in black enterprise
monthly first one you could go into
black enterprise during that period and
you could find every car at American
Express had food at there wasn't one
investment at in a black business
publication now you go split through
Forbes or fortune and you can't count
the ads right so we weren't even being
marketed to I'm glad to say that now
you'll see a lot more mutual fund ads in
black enterprise which I think we had
something to do with because I kept
saying to people this is a travesty if
you're Merrill Lynch or Goldman Sachs
whatever it might be why aren't we good
enough for the ad because we will be
good customers once you just make us
aware of what we might be missing so
it's not surprising that these numbers
look the way they do and I'm not saying
that we don't share a role and
responsibility here and I'm hoping that
a lot of this research because a wake-up
call not only for black America but for
all of America so we see that the less
of us have exposure to the stock market
the problem is when you compound the
differences in our investments over time
it's ugly
so this is the forty eight versus a
hundred thousand dollars no interesting
ly remember we don't have the same
exposure to the stock market I just grew
the
friends over 25 years at a 4% return
versus an 8% return for the white money
the difference is it's over five hundred
thousand dollars difference compounded
over time because we started off with
half the money and it's growing half as
fast now we did some math and we tried
to figure out what do you need to retire
if you make fifty thousand dollars a
year because remember that's the group
that we're surveying a fifty thousand
dollar a forty year old who makes fifty
thousand dollars a year
needs about a million won at retirement
to sustain their exact lifestyle so to
be able to pull fifty thousand dollars a
year out we always tell people just plan
on needing one hundred percent of what
you make the old rules used to say
seventy percent because people would say
your house is paid for and so you don't
have that expense well now the house
expense has been replaced by health care
costs and so as a result of that the
number is still a very very big number
so you need to plan on having one
hundred percent of your income so you
look at these numbers and you can see
again both groups won't get there but
the African American numbers are
particularly startling and it's
something that has had us worried so
what we decided to do we know that 401k
plans are the gateway to investing for
minorities so we said let's go look at
some 401k plans how do they look buy
raise maybe if we could get companies to
see that there's a difference they'll
change their marketing efforts they'll
be more attuned to this issue they'll
see that they have a responsibility to
make sure that they are actively
reaching out to their minority employees
to get them on par with their white
counterparts because what we fear is
you'll have two people sitting next to
each other in a cube with different
color skin and one more retire with a
secure retirement same job and the other
one won't and the company won't even
will not even have known that there was
a difference or an issue or a problem
there that they needed to think about so
we went to one of our customers
great-west life insurance company we
managed a lot of money for them they're
one of the largest 401k plan
administrators in the country and we
said do you think you could look at real
people by race and see if there are
difference in terms of what people are
contributing their 401k plan so they
survey 20
in people they met they they oversee for
when k plans for hundreds of thousands
but they did a twenty thousand person
sample and this is what they found
african-american males contributed 20%
less on average to the plan I'm sorry
Earned fit twenty percent less
contribute fifty eight percent less
account balances seventy five percent
smaller than white males
despite thirty three percent more
service so we've worked longer make less
contribute less and account balance it's
a quarter of our white counterpart male
african-american female very very
similar similar statistics and I think
it's one thing to look at percentages
here are the numbers these numbers scare
me to death the african-american male is
making forty nine thousand dollars the
white male is making sixty one the
African American male has two years more
service eight years these are real
people this is not hypothetical the
white American male it has been there at
the company on average for six years the
African American male is deferring less
than two percent of his income white
male is deferring four-and-a-half
percent now here's the part that
actually is where my heart starts to
skip a beat the African American male
balance is just under $12,000 and the
white male balance is forty seven
thousand twelve thousand dollars to
forty seven thousand real people this is
frightening
you cannot dig out of this hole without
a major major effort I don't think
people realize this now they went on and
they found that we are less diversified
which makes sense because when the stock
market cratered our money wasn't
diversified and spread out so we ran for
the hills I mentioned that after the
internet bubble burst African Americans
on average had one point seven funds in
their 401k plan white Americans on
average had three point six so that lack
of diversification means that there's
more volatility in our portfolio so we
tend to be more conservative and less
diversified the other thing that they
found out which I found so interesting
you know the average American has 11
jobs in their lifetime I've only had one
but that
with the statistics show now they say
the great thing about 401k plans they're
portable you can take them with you
right the problem is we aren't rolling
ours over into IRAs four percent of
african-americans who left the job
rolled it over versus 31 percent of our
white counterparts so not surprising
that our account balances are much lower
right four percent rolled it over versus
31 percent and this is for emphasis
because the the dichotomy here is just
startling and I can tell you I've been
to the biggest mutual fund companies in
America I've been to the biggest
brokerage firms and I said houston we
have a problem and people look at me
like I have no idea what you're talking
about and we show them this data and
they're like well and I say just from
selfish reasons just think if you could
increase these numbers it'd be good
business for you right not to mention
the fact that you'd have the community
leaving more financially secure so just
so you didn't think that it was just one
company we looked at John and I went to
every company where we're on the board
so I went to DreamWorks Estee Lauder and
Starbucks he went to McDonald's a on
insurance company and exelon which is
one of the largest public utilities in
America so exelon looked at this and
they have a lot of union workers
different types of groups I just want to
show you one statistic saving rates were
lower but this is the one I want to show
you not contributing enough to get the
match free money right free money
thirty four percent of the African
Americans who work for the company did
not contribute enough to get the match
versus 14 percent of the white Americans
remember same jobs same educational
levers 34 percent versus versus 14
percent that's so interesting because I
have a lot of African Americans who come
to me and they say I don't want to lose
anything if I invest in your mutual
funds because we invest in small and
medium sized companies and I always like
to explain to them I said well you know
this is the thing we're in the for
example the Walmart 401k plan which is a
great plan to be in four million
employees great great plan so Walmart
401k plan I went to Bentonville and
did an investment class for all of the
Walmart people and so they were like you
know we don't want to lose any money and
I said well this is the thing your
company matches $0.50 on a dollar so we
all know this in this room it's a 50%
return right right off the bat you
haven't done anything and you've already
gotten a 50% return so you could just
think of it that way it will Olay some
of the concerns you have about being
invested in the stock market so one
other place that we went McDonald's it's
ok this is Golden Arches how much do we
all love McDonald's right I love
McDonald's when I was a little kid I ate
McDonald's every day and I always joke
with John who loves McDonald's way more
than me and now I wish it with him well
I'm still single so I can't eat
McDonald's but you can eat it as much as
you want and he's like no we have
healthy food like no I don't eat the
scone at Starbucks either so just so you
know or that Frappuccino which tastes so
good but it's your calories for a day so
McDonald's case study so they looked at
managers of their restaurants now this
is something I did not know it's a
fascinating statistic about McDonald's
30% of their corporate officers come out
of their restaurants today 30% so the
pipeline of their restaurants is a very
very important place for them to recruit
their great talent and that's why I
think the Golden Arches people
McDonald's people they bleed for that
place I mean they really have a squirt
esprit de corps that I have never seen
before they still talk about Ray Kroc as
if he's alive no they do it's like well
what would ray say you know John comes
back and brings me he brought me though
John had to as a board member
read the Ray Kroc biography grinding it
out which I read as well because John
was so you know taken with it you know
he's practically weeping reading about
Ray because that's the way that they
have built that culture and it works
trust me it's a wonderful story success
story and wonderful business story so
McDonald's looked at the restaurant
managers John asked a question in 2004
have you ever looked at your 401k plan
by race they did 50 percent of their
african-american restaurant managers
were participating in their 401k plan
versus 90 percent of the white
restaurant manager
okay so just so we know that this isn't
an elitist issue this is McDonald's
restaurant managers 50% of the African
Americans were in the 401k plan versus
ninety percent of the white individuals
doing the exact same job right so again
we see this over and over and over again
so they actually decided to do something
about it they put forth an effort that I
think companies could learn from that it
was phenomenal one of the things that
they did is they decided that they were
going to automatically enroll everyone
in the company in a 401k in the 401k
plan they were going to enroll them at
1% of their salary and then they were
going to give everyone in the company a
1% raise so that no one missed the
nickel out of their paycheck not only
did the black number go to 95 percent in
3 years the white number 1 to 95 percent
so everyone got lifted in terms of
participation and account balances
across the entire company despite race
why not why did this was the African
American restaurant managers there in
2004 they had 12 point six million
dollars on average in the in the plan it
was a 41% by 2007 and so just this you
can see this is when you just sort of
shine a light on this issue you can
actually see some real meaningful
results so before I close I don't
believe in just admiring a problem
that's what we call it at Arial we say
if we're like kicking around an issue we
say we've admired the problem long
enough so I feel like I've admired this
problem long enough so there are three
things that I can be I think that can be
done to change the whole paradigm on
financial literacy and retirement
security in this country first and
foremost I think the individual needs to
understand it is a new day and we are
all ultimately accountable for our own
future so they saw our idea of thinking
about the company taking care of us or
social security there's been a dramatic
shift and some of us just haven't quite
understood oh my god I'm in charge so
the individual ultimately bears full
responsibility I never want to move away
from that secondly I think every
corporation should look at a 401k plan
by Ray
I think if they saw the data they would
do something like McDonald's did and
that ultimately would have a positive
that not only in terms of their
relationship with their employees but
also in terms of making sure that
they've done everything that they can to
put their employees on the right path
last but not least and I know it won't
come as a surprise to you I think
financial literacy should be taught in
every school in America that's my
crusade right now that I want every high
school in America to have financial
literacy and every grade school in
America to have a financial literacy
program so we've done it at Arial at one
school and I'd like to show you a little
bit about it before I go you could roll
the second video
what's the economic word for people that
you're describing your discussion what
are they what are they good morning
areum this is Dominic lily and Jen's
what the time is 9:11 but I am it is
time for the mid morning market update
the DAP is currently down 5.4 0.4
percent the Nasdaq is probably down 1.0
0.6 percent the S&P 500 is currently
then one point or one point of that
music we have been invested in stocks
such as Aeropostale
Tiffany's apples and go so I want to
keep up with our money so we did the
market update so we can follow our
stocks and we go to Nasdaq because it
has the rate and it has quotes that
people are talking about about the mark
if I didn't go to area I wouldn't know
how much I would be spending and
stalling I wouldn't know how to save
because sometimes you'll you'll see like
2 4 5 and that makes you think that you
have to buy two but really you only have
to buy one so some people get tricked
better so that's my parents I've learnt
how to trade stocks and invest docs and
how to research box and analyze I'm
pretty good at what I do and I know
about about stocks and companies and I
have to have my own stock portfolio who
thinks the US has a lot of investments
Derrick what do you think students learn
about investing
they learn about economics concepts that
most kids in public schools don't even
get exposure to at such a young age and
they also have the added aspect of an
international investments course in the
seventh grade so they're really creating
well-rounded students who have an
understanding of economics investing and
international component
like just as community know about
investing in stock to the stock
marketing how all that works my mother
be like would she's learned I'm like
yeah I have learned about some of the
stocks in the stock market and stuff
she'd be like oh I need you to help me
with this sometimes I'm saving for when
I get to high school in college for
books and everything and just for me
just to have I think that I am actually
ahead of some other kids that aren't
learning about investments and others in
stocks because we get on to subjects
like like basically I remember I've
gotten to apply for my friend about the
war in Iraq and I look at it from a
business perspective she were telling
from well if we pull out dad dad that's
going to happen like well if we pull out
that that does gonna happen to the
economy she's like why are you talking
about the economy our students are
learning anything from what's scarcity
and what is opportunity costs all the
way to what's the best investment in
their stock portfolios and should they
if they brought Apple now something
comes out with Apple should they buy
sell or hold so that whole spectrum is
where they go from kindergarten through
eighth grade who doesn't love to talk
about money that's really makes it fun
so we give our kids $20,000 in first
grade real money and it follows them
through their grade school career they
take over increasing responsibilities
for managing the money when they're in
eighth grade they give $20,000 back to
the incoming first grade class to make
the program self-perpetuating in sixth
grade they start picking their own
stocks they take a quarter of the
portfolio seventh grade half of the
portfolio eighth grade the full
portfolio to replicate what we did what
John Rogers had as a child they get
statements at home every quarter so they
get mail and the profits at the end of
the grade school career are split half
where they have to make a philanthropic
contribution because our kids are
inner-city kids and the other half they
split and for every child that will put
the money in a 420 529 plan for college
we give them an additional thousand
dollars so that we're trying to teach
them about matching and 401k plans early
last year we had 44 kids graduate 42 we
ask their parents to let them make their
own decision put the money in the 529
plan for college and so this has been
our real-life experience our school is
14 years old now so we've had three
graduating classes and these kids are
absolutely completely obsessed with the
stock market because to them it's like
sports
my favorite part my favorite last
closing story about the kids the our
kids come to our office to sing
Christmas carols so they require their
440 kids in our school we share the
building with the University of Chicago
charter school ours is not a charter
school because it happened before there
was charter school legislation in
Chicago the mayor gave nine institutions
the right to run a school there were
hundreds of applications and we actually
won one they asked us to name our school
Arial which we had some trepidation
about because there had never been a
black company to have a school so they
thought that that would send a really
great message to the community I have to
tell you when you put your company name
on a school you think about another
totally different way it's not something
you ever can walk away from so we were a
little nervous about that saying wow you
know we are reputation and could be
augmented or affected in a negative way
by doing this but ultimately we decided
to do it it has been a great wonderful
experiment and great experience
but getting back to the Christmas Carol
so they came the ship to Ariel our
buildings at the Aeon Center which is a
landmark building in Chicago on the 29th
floor so the kids come to do sing
Christmas carols and as you saw they all
wear uniforms you know blue shirts and
light blue shirts and dark pants and
ties and things for girls so they come
in to signa carols and the teacher comes
up to me and she says miss Hobson Julia
did not wear her uniform today
Julia was 9 years old so I'm looking
down on her this is a few years ago you
know she's little and I'm like Julia is
very very important I didn't know her
it's very very important for you to do
what your teacher says and it's very
important that you wear your uniform and
I'm going into you know the speech that
we've all had right from our parents so
Julia looks up at me and she says no you
do not understand this t-shirt is Old
Navy and we own the gap and this is
advertising because that stock needs
help
I still well up when I tell the story
and I looked at her nice it they get it
they get it they think like owners Julie
is trying to move a gap stock in our
office so I know what this can do and I
hope as you go out into the world and do
all the unbelievably great things that
you will do that you'll remember this
one small growing problem it's
disproportionate effect on the minority
communities and what it ultimately means
for all of American society so thank you
very very much for having me I'm happy
to take a few questions
you have any plans to expand the school
concept to within Chicago and I've been
outside of the state what we've been
doing we we've had three initiatives
going on one we actually have I've hired
a person full-time at aerial who
actually splits his time I should say
between us and the Chicago Public School
System he works for Arne Duncan who runs
the Chicago Public School System who
came from our office before he went to
run the school system Arne actually was
the fount the father and and and a
thought leader behind our school and is
now running the third largest school
system in America
Peter Cunningham who works for us is
full-time spending his life trying to
get financial literacy in schools both
in Chicago and nationally so we've
engaged a lobbyist firm in Washington
and we're working with congressional
leaders to really put this on the agenda
as you might expect from Chicago we're
good friends with Barak and we've also
raised this issue with him as well so
we've decided instead of me talking
about it this year I said we were hiring
someone and this is their job to get
this done secondly in Chicago we've gone
to some of the biggest most successful
families in Chicago and we said the
Arenal program should be replicated we
need $20,000 for every school and if we
just start with the one the first 20
through the one through eight then the
program becomes self-perpetuating we've
estimated that we need 20 million
dollars to put it in every school so
we're trying to find like-minded people
who will contribute to that thirdly we
are actually formalizing our financial
curriculum so that any school in America
could ask for the aerial curriculum and
get it off the shelf with beautiful
workbooks and lesson plans and be able
to go from there the one major obstacle
is we have to teach the teachers it's
not like the teachers have been savvy
about investments as well so we have to
do a lot of work with our teachers just
to get them aware of this we have full
time investment teachers at Ariel that
we pay for that would never be in a
school system budget so we recognize
we've got to figure out ways to tweak
this program we can't do more schools
because we're actually an investment
company not a school company and we
spend about a million dollars a year on
this just out of our own
get so would that's the Cadillac version
we have 11 full-time people our
principal has an assistant we have all
sorts of things that most schools don't
have but we do think there's a Chevy
version that can be done and that other
companies can take up yes hi thank you
for coming what could we do here in
business schools or other professional
schools like law school medical school
because my hunch is that beyond just the
seventh-grade kids that this might
actually be a difference even at the
Stanford undergraduate level even
amongst our community here so what could
we do to help this effort
well it's interesting um one of the
people that we work with with Charles
Schwab and company for a long time was a
woman named Carla Foster and Carla went
to Stanford Business School and Carla
told me she worked at Schwab in a very
senior level she said I had no idea
about investing Z there and I've gone to
the best schools in society in America
in the world and so we do recognize you
know I didn't have I mean maybe if you
took corporate finance somewhere you
have some sense of these things but you
know most of us don't really get that
front-row view so even in in the elite
schools for lack of a better term it's
an issue in terms of what you can do I
think a lot of what you can do is when
you walk out of these doors one you're
going to be inside great organizations
so many I know business school students
are going into the financial services
field you could spur a company to take
on this effort by having a school as
well and also asking companies to look
at their 401k plan by race those are two
things it actually seems so small but
could make a difference thirdly I told
people replicate the John Rogers story
give stocks for to nieces and nephews
and children for birthdays and Christmas
instead of buying the PlayStation buy
the Sony shares maybe not Sony because
it hasn't done so well but
it's so that you socialize children to
save you investment investing at a very
early age everyone in this room could do
that and then last one at least you can
talk about the problem because I feel
like if we start a grassroots movement
around this will actually end up moving
the needle melody on behalf of the black
business students and the Graduate
School of Business we offer you a bottle
of vision cellars wine it's a black
vintner we decided to support black
entrepreneurs as much as we could in
this conference thank you so much for
your time and your gracious words and
your intelligent thoughts and your
beauty and your humor well thank you so
much for having me I just need that
letter
okay I have to tell you the punchline to
this because it's very very good so I'm
going to give him the letter so my
boyfriend I've spent a lot of time in
San Francisco's George Lucas so George
said to me if he says there is no night
school tell them if I gave him one
hundred million dollars
could they be a night school just so
that I can chop you I suggest you put in
a column